how is the position of speaker of the
house changed over time
the position of speaker of the house has
changed a lot over time and it has had
powerful early advocates henry clay an
early speaker of the house who had three
different terms as speaker of the house
used the position to shepherd all kinds
of
legislation to improve america he also
played a crucial role in john quincy
adams's becoming president because the
election was thrown into the house he
was quite powerful then the pre then the
job kind of uh got less powerful there
were periods during the civil war where
there wasn't a speaker of the house for
long periods because there was so much
contention in the congress they couldn't
pick a speaker of the house
the modern speaker of the house has
become increasingly powerful
really uh
growing with the the growth of the
federal government around let's say the
second world war various different
speakers gaining more power and in the
recent incarnation the speaker is
particularly powerful in two different
ways one is shepherding a president's
legislation if the speaker's from the
same party uh and the other is in
opposition they become essentially the
opposition speaking uh in against the
president of an opposite party so people
like that would be nancy pelosi now with
president trump or
john boehner with president obama or tip
o'neill with president reagan so they
are the the key person in doing combat
with whoever's in the white house if
they're from the opposite party